pouah
[Musique]
une autre journée plutôt dit arrête pour
marie-christine riz signaux l'eau et son
fils de 4 ans liam
pourtant la vie n'est pas toujours
simple pour la jeune femme de 32 ans qui
vit avec un bloco congénitale qui met de
la pression sur les globes oculaires de
toute mon enfance j'ai grandi avec cette
maladie là parce que c'est irréversible
il y a deux ans après une intervention
chirurgicale elle a perdu la vision dans
l'oeil droit et elle ne peut plus
percevoir qu'un peu de lumière seulement
dans son oeil gauche
ce printemps vélo bleu et médecins mans
comme nice est vraiment clair que je
m'habitue à vivre sans la vision puis
apprendre à marcher avec la canne
blanche
c'est vraiment un choc l'heure c'est une
descente aux enfers qui commence depuis
son père l'aide à surmonter les épreuves
en lui donnant un coup de main pour
l'encadrement de son fils liam
d'ailleurs n'a pas échappé à l'hérédité
il est aussi atteint du glaucome y ait
subi plusieurs chirurgies mais ça s'est
stabilisé ça va bien et puis je pense
que de l'avenir
j'ose croire meilleur que moi parce que
la technologie a pas fini nous
surprendre
en attendant marie christine et c'est de
lui faire comprendre les défis de la
cécité
pourquoi toi ma malchance dans les bacs
de récupération sur la rue 8es et qui
comprend potes et puis si je m'enligne
pas comme il faut vers l'ascenseur
mettez y sommes
ils vont me donner la main que par ici
ma notice par gentille avec moi
la pandémie et sa distanciation sociales
ont complètement changé sa vie depuis
deux mois et demi avant les gens il
s'éloigne pas de moi il venait me dire
tu besoin d'être je fais juste comme
marcher sur ma rue piszczek des fois le
monde
starz dans la rue volontairement pour me
contourner ça me fait de la peine quand
même elle qui aimait aller chercher son
pain et faire une épicerie induire non
c'est comme une grosse partie de mon
autonomie
je peux pas demander à personne qui va
vouloir que je tienne le bras qui va
vouloir m'accompagner
lakovic 19 a donc bouleversé davantage
la vie d'environ cent mille personnes
qui ont une déficience visuelle au
québec il ya des files d'attentes
partout comment on fait pour savoir où
est le début ou à la fin
comment on fait pour suivre les lignes
par terre les chiens guides n'ont pas
pris non plus à se mettre en ligne
alors on se fait avertir par des gens
qu'on respecte pas la distanciation
alors qu'au peuple
l'association de pascal dussault a
interpellé le gouvernement québécois son
succès nous ce qu'on dit c'est si chacun
un masque si l'on des gains on voit pas
le problème pourquoi il pourrait pas
aller au magasin et être accompagnés
marie-christine les signaux l'eau vient
d'avoir rendez vous à l'hôpital pour
planifier un traitement elle en est
ressortie déçue j'ai des yeux compliqué
il ya deux semaines je peux aider pas
nouvellement plus à faire c'est comme on
essaie des choses ça donne des résultats
mais jamais pour très longtemps
salut je m'appelle marie christine et
bienvenue à mme enveloppe mais rien pour
la décourager
elle s'est depuis lancé dans des
conférences et dans le tournage de
capsules vidéo avec des vedettes auquel
et lancent des défis de vivre à
l'aveuglette
ces prêts atteint même temps la wii et
elle a dû aussi s'adapter aux défis de
la distanciation sociales causées par le
virus
quand on voit pas il pas l'important la
communication vient étayer fallu que je
trouve une autre stratégie donc là j'ai
décidé des phares m enlève sur les
réseaux sociaux des gens qui n'ont pas
de limites même s'ils sont différents
donc marie-christine je pense que fait
tout et peut tout faire
cette force là la trouve je pense avec
son fils pas question pour elle donc de
s'apitoyer sur son sort j'ai fait la
paix plus rapidement avec ma perte de
vision parce que j'ai déjà vu l
impression qu avoir vu c'est ça mon prix
de consolation c'est que je me sens
tellement connectés encore avec tout
qu'est ce que j'ai vu avant
owen
si je te dis ferme les yeux et imaginez
un arc en ciel si on va le voir l'arc
ancien démon si je le vois un arc en
ciel devenu symbole de cette patience
face à une pandémie qui n'épargne le
quotidien de personnes